So what are you going to do? I'm
not going to stop seeking revenge,
so I have a suggestion: I
told you that people like Mr. Punch are kind, so
don't fight them.  Or
should I say, I'm rejecting it.Also, I've allowed you to accompany me, but let me make this clear.Please don't get in my way.Yes,
that
and that.I want to
reaffirm my magic.The magic of love is to make a
man fall in love with you and then manipulate you.
If we met in Lydia, then why didn't you cast that spell on me?
That day
in Lydia, when we first met,
Ophelia must have ordered me to be abducted, even if it meant using some other magic.
But
you didn't cast a spell on me
Why? Why did you try to convince me? Because
even
Adonis wouldn't want that kind of first meeting,
right?
[Music] That's
the worst
[Music]
DET